bable protocol activated what what's
what's Babel protocol why am i kicking
its the self-destruct sequence
what struck I'm sorry have we not faced
an evil version of Barry before my
mistake
do you have an update sir if one has
been located he's safe
locked up in the metahuman wing of iron
Heights as we speak he's right where you
want with him what do we do now now we
find the others
[Music]
hey everybody now we find the others so
this is gonna be my episode 2 video it
was crazy with Easter eggs there was
even some a Loki arrow crossover so
there's a new round of that Justice
League ticket giveaway I'll announce a
winner at the end of this all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so let's just
get into it so top 10 WTF I'll do Easter
eggs as we go along number 10 they open
on Oliver's old apartment some tech
billionaires buying it before he's taken
down by Kilgore if you didn't recognize
this we've seen it so many times in the
last couple of seasons on arrow a bunch
of different people have lived in it but
physically it's been located in Star
City so I think they're just using this
set and it's not the actual Oliver's
apartment so it's not like the Central
City Police Department heard about the
crime and then came all the way to Star
City to solve it because they would have
had the Star City police there too so it
gets a little meta I don't know if
they're still using this apartment on
arrow though but the set is still there
they didn't blow it up so it might still
be around but the other big arrow
crossover is when they pick up the
newspaper outing Oliver as the Green
Arrow so this is why you need to watch
arrow because this is a direct reference
to something that happened at the very
end of arrow episode 1 last week
somebody outed him on live television
so of course all the news outlets are
reporting it now and they'll address
that big info bomb on arrow episode 2
this Thursday so you can watch to find
out what happens and what comes from
this but obviously people are starting
to learn about Oliver being the green
arrow so we'll talk about that during my
arrow video in a couple days but then as
they said that the Lightning the tone
this year they cut to the Bob Seger
montage from a risky business with Barry
doing his best Tom Cruise impression if
you haven't seen that movie it's
actually a really good movie and he
drops all kinds of Easter eggs while
he's doing his binge watch at a thousand
times the pace that you would normally
watch television shows so it turns out
that Barry and Oliver watch a whole
bunch of HBO he makes a couple of Game
of Thrones references Cisco makes a
Silicon Valley reference later in the
episodes so I guess they're just huge
fans of those shows but now we know the
Game of Thrones and HBO exist within the
world of flash and arrow the funny thing
about that too is that I know now
because he told me Stephen Amell watches
Game of Thrones videos because that's
one of his favorite shows in real life -
so Barry and Oliver watch Game of
Thrones but also the actors in real life
are big fans but everybody's a big fan
of Game of Thrones number seven cisco
unveils the new suit and we learn about
all its different abilities over the
course of the episode but it has like
that big life raft that turns him into
the fat flash that's right out of the
comics you probably seen this cover that
was a story where a villain shot him
with a gun to increase his mass to slow
him down he was trying to keep him from
running SuperSpeed he wasn't actually
trying to make him fat we learned that
it has an automatic Speed Force pulse
cannon that the suit itself can control
there's an AI system and it has a
heads-up display Iron Man style so a lot
of you were riding iron flash in my
Twitter timeline but we also learn
number seven the babble protocol really
is the Batman Tower of Babel protocol
his contingency plan for taking out the
members of the Justice League in case
they go rogue haven't we faced an evil
version of Barry before the solution
that iris came up with too shocking
himself with his own lightning throw is
also sort of a callback to season 2
episode 2 the first time he learned to
throw lightning so like I said lots of
callbacks to the first couple of seasons
number six we learned all about
Kilgore's backstory on the TV show so
he's a comic book character but he's
more of a brainiac type character in the
comics on the TV show they're turning
him into more of a metahuman character
who got his powers through something
that the thinker did he says we need to
find the others I'll address this too
because it's one of my big WTF moments
but whatever it was that happened to
them sounds like something that happened
to the thinker so like he isn't somebody
who's being really evil in experimenting
on other people
but their shared experience gave them
all of their powers so in the world of
the show the name Kilgore was the app
that he was developing with the other
billionaires that screwed him over Mark
Zuckerberg style so if you haven't seen
the social network it's actually a
really good David Fincher movie but
that's basically what happens in that
movie is sort of a satirical version of
the story of how Mark Zuckerberg sort of
screwed over the people that helped
develop Facebook Zuckerberg I was
Zuckerberg young people before
Zuckerberg balls dropped
I'm the devil what
but in the comics Kilgore is an alien
intelligence who comes to earth and
needs other technology to survive so he
just starts taking over other tech he's
not cybernetic or anything like that but
after berry defeats him he comes back in
a Justice League story and takes over
the mind of Maxwell Lord so number five
there was a whole bunch of relationship
comedy in the episode Catelyn is sort of
the funny advisor like Oh me and Ronnie
we actually had some counseling together
so Ronnie name-dropped there's all kinds
of season 1 callbacks in this episode
well number one when a girl says it's
fine it's not fine amen I'm gonna go but
the biggest ones during therapy about
them talking about all the people that
have died so far all their friends
Barry's like yeah my mom died oh my dad
died too he's actually watched his mom
die on three separate occasions once
when he was a little kid the very first
time the second time when he went back
at the end of season 1 to save her he
had to watch her die again and then at
the end of flashpoint during the
beginning of season 3 but they're like
Ronnie died snart died HR died my mom
Eddie we grew up together they're just
making fun of all the crazy issues that
they have and there are a lot like when
you think about it it's like oh man
that's messed up but the whole reason
for that is number four is the Barry
came back and apparently his binge watch
didn't include all the relevant data on
the city so everything has changed in
the last six months and he has no idea
what's going on so he's just running
around making all kinds of mistakes not
because he's dumb but just because he
assumes that everything is the same and
it's not so probably the bigger moment
from this therapy session is where iris
flat-out admits that she was totally not
cool with Barry going back into the
speedforce even though he did it for the
right reasons she's still really bitter
about that and they don't solve that in
this episode so that will probably
continue even if they don't go back to
therapy in a future episode but aside
from that Green Arrow moment probably
the funniest thing about this is when
she's first trying to pitch him the idea
of therapy and he hears he got some
special advice from Caitlin about
relationships so they make it look like
he thinks she got some hot sex tips
until she drops the therapy bomb on him
and it just stops him short
and then there's all the Cisco dirty
magazine jokes too I wish you were
looking at a dirty magazine when gypsy
catches him like this is somehow worse
than you looking at naked women but
number three all the gypsy stuff so this
is sort of teeing up
breacher her father coming on in a
couple episodes he's not coming on right
away but it's not meant to be like a big
villain situation even though he's a
villain in the comics they're just
teasing that their relationship is
getting very serious in the thing I'm
wondering about this too is that she's
not gonna be around that much the back
half of the season so there's gonna have
to be some big WTF reason for her not to
be around even though it seems like
their relationship is ramping up to the
next level like they're not at Barry and
iris level that I gonna get married
anytime soon
but something crazy has got to happen in
the next couple of episodes for them but
number two they take Kilgore to iron
Heights prison he doesn't seem all that
concerned with it like he's right where
he wants to be the warden is somebody we
need from the comics if you haven't been
reading the rebirth comics literally
just the last issue this past week
introduced the warden in the rebirth
universe he's not necessarily an evil
character but there was a plot line and
I'll explain this a little bit more if
it turns out that they're actually doing
this where there were people inside iron
Heights prison experimenting on inmates
so that might be what that post-credit
scene was a reference to so like you see
the warden look in here with this really
evil smile like he's got plans for
Kilgore like oh maybe he's doing this to
other inmates too so number one of
course was the thinker post-credits
scene where he says time to find the
others and you see this board with 12
slots Kilgore is the first one so they
imply that all of these people got their
powers through some crazy experiment it
probably has something to do with what
the warden and maybe the thinker is tied
up in now my initial takeaway was that
maybe the warden might be working with
the thinker but I think the way that
they played it the thinker didn't come
away seeming very evil in this scene the
warden seemed like the evil person so
maybe the thinker was a victim of
something that the warden did or
something related and he's trying to do
something good but through his actions
will become the big bat of the season
because they told us that the thinker is
the big villain this season but looking
at the warden here doesn't he just
feel like a much bigger villain after
the end of this episode so let me know
in the comments what was your favorite
moment and what do you think is going on
with the warden the thinker in these 12
metahumans that got their powers from
some other crazy experiment just to drop
another big info bomb no spoilers but we
found out when the reverse-flash is
coming back exactly but because it's
super spoilery and they haven't released
an official promo or official images for
it I'm not gonna include them in this
video or say which episode but you might
know what I'm talking about he's coming
back a little sooner than I expected
but I am 99.9% sure of the way that he's
coming back and how that's gonna work
but if you really want me to make a
video for it just let me know if you
want me to do reverse-flash but what
will happen is I'll do a trailer video
for next week's episode next then I have
some Titans Nightwing to post and then
obviously we have arrow on Thursday so
congratulations to Jason Todd you're
this week's giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'll announce a new winner when
I post that trailer video you can click
here for all my other flash and you can
click here to rewatch that Black Panther
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight